hello everyone and welcome to yet
another couch list video now I know I
still owe you the story behind the last
time the cars disappeared and we will
get to that it's really not my fault the
couch isn't here and I'm still late with
the story you know it's coming any time
now so be ready for it but getting back
to this game we are still at the 1916
arrives tournament in New York we've
skipped a few rounds we said we will not
be covering all of them but capablanca
is six and six so six wins in a row and
here he faces a very strong American
chess master Jacob Bernstein not to be
mistaken with Joseph Bernstein Kobe
Blancas old nemesis from the San
Sebastiano mint of 1911 who protested
for about capablanca even participating
as he hasn't really qualified in any big
international tournament this is a
different different gentleman he's been
New York champion three years in a row
and as you'll see in this game he is
quite a strong player and well it's
better just to show you the game so
without further ado no not without
further ado as I really thought I will
not be able to find a photo of mr. Jacob
Bernstein but you know to my delight I
was able to find and it's really an
amazing photo I really want to show it
to you it's from 1915 so it was taken a
year before this tournament was played
also in New York and all a lot of
similar faces will be in it so here it
is I do hope you enjoy it
there it is in the front you can see Cup
a bunker facing Edward Lasker and the
table next to them is jacob bernstein
facing none other than Frank James
Marshall and a lot of interesting faces
in the background and not all of them
were identified to date but I've found a
link to chess history website I will put
a link to it in the description below so
you can check it out it will be the
first thing you see if you want to learn
more about this photo and about all the
nice people in it so getting back to the
game
Jacob Bernstein has the white pieces and
he opens with E 4 we have E 5 by
capablanca Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
now Knight to c3
so deviating a bit from the real opus we
have the three Knights game but couple
uncle goes Knight f6 so it's the four
Knights game we have Bishop to b5 just
going for a nice Spanish variation and
Bishop to b4 we have the similar
variation both players Castle here we
have Bernstein castles Capablanca
castles and now d3 kappa blanka goes d6
continues the symmetry and here Bishop
to g5 and here one other example where
it's impossible to keep the symmetry
going forever here if black goes Bishop
to g4 it's just better for white just
backup captures and now if Queen
captures ninety five wins the game
because after the Queen moves you just
removed the defender of the bishop on b4
captures and now white will be up a
piece or in a different matter if you
play Bishop captures on f6 black can
also play Bishop captures on f3 but then
now just Queen captures Queen captures
Queen captures G captures and again
Bishop to d5 threatens the same idea
winning the bishop on b4 as you're
threatening to remove the defender but
you're definitely winning at least d f6
pawn you will gain material you will
have a better position so one nice
example of why when it's again
impossible to keep the symmetry going so
here we have Bishop captures on c3
Capablanca decides to give up the bishop
pair but he will get some nice counter
play in return so be captured since e3
and now Queen to e7 Bernstein continues
developing pieces we have worked
II won the rook no defense d4 pawn and
the white is preparing d4 we have night
d8 my capablanca doesn't allow white to
double up couple won't respond and he
also is preparing to remain over the
knight into the center and depend on
what white place and maybe you know go
for the f4 square or maybe just you know
attack the bishop go for some some other
squares but white continues with this
plan we have d4 as the e4 pawn is
protected and now Bishop to g4 by
Capablanca pinning the night and here
white decides that okay the bishop no
longer has any future here Bishop to f1
just talks that there's a pin for later
it's a nice defensive piece doesn't
allow black to develop the in any sort
of pawn storm by attacking the bishop
and also it could be a nice defensive
piece and he will be able to use it
later
Knights the east sides by capablanca now
strengthening the d4 square but also
attacking the bishop here and here
Bernstein
so wait the dark square bishop as well
bishop to see one so we have the bishops
on starting squares but of course it's
still a bishop pair you know if you're
able to develop them later it will still
be a great advantage and here kappa
blanka plays a very nice move Bishop
captures on f3 and he gives a white a
choice do you wanna play Queen captures
on f3 and allow the e-cat force on d4
where you would just lose a very nice
pawn you could go Bishop to b2 here you
could go look here well not so greatest
captures and allowing this night to come
to d4 while attacking the Queen but
Queen captures on f3 is the safest
choice for white but Bernstein wants to
keep everything together
he wants a monster center as you can see
here he wants to keep his bishop pair
and sometimes well especially in chess
you can't always have everything so
Knights the h5 by Capablanca he goes for
this very nice f4 square and also he's
threatening some very nice ideas first
bishop to h3 by white and now the night
comes to f4 and here if you're not
careful well you could you could easily
suffer ideas like Queen to g5 check so
here we have Bishop to g4 trying to
block everything and the night was the
bishop was under attack on h3 and now
just h5 by kappa blanka forcing
bernstein to capture on e6 with Bishop
captures on e6f captures on e6 now
opening the F file for the rook and now
King to h1 a very important move if you
play a slow mode like rugby 1 just Queen
g5 checked least the checkmate King
d'fwan Queen g2 will be checkmated the
night covers D 2 square so after F
captures on e6 King h1 at least now
Queen g5 it doesn't come with check so
nice to h3 now Capablanca is threatening
Knight captures on f2 which will give
check and win the Queen on d1 so Bishop
to e3 burns in defense d f2 pawn and now
Queen to h4 just bringing the Queen into
the game piling up on the f2 pawn the
idea is to rook f7 bring the other group
to f8 double are crooks along the F file
it's a very unpleasant position for
white but you know white try to keep
everything together and it's it's very
hard to do that Quinta e2 defending
twice the DF to pawn and capablanca
just plays rook to f7 he's preparing to
double up on the effect on the a file
and white doesn't really have any active
moves here yes he does have the monster
center here as you can see this house
basically of pawns in the in the center
of the board but he doesn't have an
active move so here he finds the only
active move he has but he has to give up
some material rook the g1 he offers
capablanca the exchange but at least he
will be able to activate the rook well
along the the G file a couple banca
gladly accepts this we have nightcap
Tristan g1 rook captures on g1 and now
just Queen back to f6 piling up on the
f3 pawn and also not allowing any sneaky
ideas like Bishop to h6 but it's just a
just a very powerful position for
capablanca rook the g3 now defending the
f3 pawn and here we have e captures on
d4 by Capablanca Bishop captures and now
comes C 5 pushing the bishop back bishop
goes back to e3 and now queen to east
six
capablanca here plans a very devious
idea but you will see that very soon
here we have Bishop to g5 by white going
after the h5 pawn and Capablanca Blanco
just doubles rooks on the F file so what
do you do here
well you are kind of threatening the g7
pawn so here Queen to f1 preparing Queen
g1 to put at least some pressure along
the G file s capablanca will definitely
capture on f3
so capablanca does this we have Queen
rook captures on f3 Queen to g1 now
putting some pressure along the G file
also the threat is rook captures on h5
so what do you do here first couple
Blanca defends the g7 point once we've
worked 80 to f7 defending the pawn and
now comes up characters on h5 so it's a
very interesting position a very dynamic
position Bernstein sacrificed the
exchange the gate the gain some counter
play how do you continue this game with
the black pieces now there is there are
a lot of ways you can continue this but
the wakeup of Marco plated is just well
it's just art so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the idea
capablanca found in this position as
just you know it's just wonderful well I
have a nice sip of my water for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
spotter of triangles and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show here
kappa blanka played rook captures on e3
now of course you could capture the pawn
on a to create a passed pawn in a 7 and
then just push that one to victory but
that's a boring way to do it kibou
blanca doesn't mind playing boring moves
if it's winning this capturing your
nature is completely winning but the
move kappa blanka played rook captures
and e3 is just much faster and it's just
beautiful and the waterway again the
seventh win in a row in this tournament
so what do you do here of course you
have to capture the rook otherwise
you're just well down a hole rook
so f captures and III was played and now
comes the move you have to find there
the glitch on the interface already
showed it to you but quintus e4 is the
idea and then it connects rook to f1 and
the Queen from c4 can control defense
the rook on f1 and there is no way for
whites to prevent this it's just too
powerful Queen to c4 was played by kappa
blanka the threat is rook to f1 winning
the Queen so can you do something about
this you could try rook f5 just blocking
the rook but it doesn't work Queen
captures on e4 with Czech will pick up
the rook so easy win for for Capablanca
on the other hand you could try King G
to just you know control DF 1 square
twice with the Queen and the king but
then Quinta e to check picks up the rook
on h5 so again you've done nothing here
really so the only thing white had left
to try well it's moved 29 so of course
Bernstein didn't want to resign just yet
a lot in kappa blanka to create a
miniature he played rook to g5 at least
while
rook to f1 comes he will have some
threats along the g7 file
rook to f1 of course was played by
Capablanca rook the g7 check we have
King to f8 and now truth the g8 check
King to e7 we have grouped the g7 check
King to e8 rooked g8 check and docking
to d7
we have rook the g7 check and here cover
Blanca just tucked his King back to
safety on the c6 square there are no
more checks anymore and here
white will just lose the Queen rook 2g4
was played keeping an eye on the e4 pawn
but now just rook captures on g1 we have
King captures and g1 and now finally
Queen captures on a - it's you have to
play something but this is now the
fastest way to win this game
white played h4 started to push his
passed pawn but here kappa blanka just
played Queen captures on c2 I would of
course threats of Queen d1 check
picking up the rook so here we have
looked to g3 getting through a crowd of
harm's way and now just a 5 and it was
now finally in this position that
American chess master Jacob Bernstein
resigned the game black pawn is just
much faster well you can just continue
pushing this pawn but then black can
just capture here you can give up the
Queen for the pawn if you want and your
point your past one will of course be
much faster so there's there's no point
in continuing this game but yeah just a
wonderful victory for Hosea Blanca 7th
win in a row in this tournament he's
doing you know wonderful wonderful work
and a beautiful victory just this rook
captures and III just a very powerful
idea here getting rid of this f1 opening
up the F file and creating this well not
that but this wonderful triangle yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
let's check out the photo one more time
because it is just amazing such nice
high-quality photo from 1915 over over a
hundred years ago is just just amazing
and look at them you know alas we're
deep in thought in the position
capablanca just posing for the photo
also Oh Jacob Bernstein posing even
better and Marshall also posing you
don't know who's a better poser here but
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it and if you
want to learn more about the follow the
first link in the description below
we'll take you to the chess history
website where you can read about it so
yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed it
and the photo I promise I will return
with the couch story I would like to
thank Torben Anderson James Lewis Brian
Powell Jack Neary and Thomas Blake for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the couple Blanca Saga
checking up on your suggestions and
the green key is coming up so we have
that as well thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day